carlotta für mich ist er schon lange der
minister der ausgrenzung und er hat
wieder einmal bewiesen dass er es
bleiben will erinnern wir uns einmal
zurück an eine zeit die für viele ganz
schlimm war zweig im winter diese
fürchterliche spaltung die wir erlebt
haben wir haben menschen in gruppen
einsortiert du bist geimpft du bist
nicht geimpft du bist solidarisch weil
du bist du bist nicht solidarisch weil
du nicht geimpft wird die zeit war
fürchterlich und sie war falsch unser
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach der
unterscheidet immer noch auch jetzt
zwischen den guten geimpften und den
bösen die sich gegen die impfung
entschieden haben und hat sich erst
gestern über demonstranten echauffiert
und ich möchte ihnen das gerne hier
einmal zeit
runter spielen habe dazu keinen beitrag
geleistet
[Applaus]
walt verdanken